in concert is the longest running and
most awarded show here in vegas so it's
safe to say they've earned their diva
status okay so twist on the popular show
is their special production called
legendary divas and here to tell us more
about that
is adele
you finally made it here to vegas
i'm here it's so exciting i love it i
love it you are actually janae longo the
adele impersonator congratulations thank
you this is your very first show in
vegas it absolutely is how does it feel
it's been an amazing roller coaster and
i've it's just been a blast can i can i
um ask you to speak in your adele accent
the entire i'm kidding did you want me
to talk about oh my god
so tell us how long you've been
impersonating adele well how long has
this journey been for you well um i have
been a cruise ship singer and working
professionally as a singer for over 20
years so i've
i definitely have
sang her songs but as an as a
tribute artist
since about december 7th oh
my gosh wow yeah it's been really
exciting so when we come to see legend
legendary divas this is a fresh concept
absolutely for you and for everyone else
so tell us about the concert which what
we should expect um well we have four
amazing vocalists
elisa fur as um celine lisa mclowery as
cher
tierney allen as lady gaga and then of
course frank marino i'm singing who is
like amazing so
far it's just been it's an amazing show
it's all live stream there's some clips
absolutely
rocking out it's a little lady mom a lot
but it is it's just brilliant there's so
much talent on that stage we have live
dancing
live singing live musicians and yeah
it's just a real honor to be a part of
it all it's something you must see um
lastly here lastly here you know you
guys have a special treat for adele and
celine fans who have been wanting we do
we do indeed absolutely tell everybody
about that really quick yeah uh well
anyone who had celine dion tickets or
adele tickets if you bring your ticket
to the box office you will get a free
ticket to legends and concert where you
will see
all of those beautiful all these
talented people so yeah it's really
exciting well congratulations again you
are so fabulous oh my god have you met
adele yet i have not fingers crossed
i can't wait for you to make that right
video of that moment okay legends and
concerts legendary divas is at the
tropicana wednesday through monday at 7
30 uh dark dark tuesdays by the way yes
tickets legends in concert.com and now
adele ladies and gentlemen
there ain't no gold
in this river
that i've been washing my hands in
forever
i know there is hope
in these waters
but i can't bring myself to swim when i
am drowning in this silence baby
let
me
go
easy on me baby
i was still a child
didn't get the chance to
we